so
good we one
minute Hi We are
TWICE Hi We are Hi
everyone I'm somi We
are and are and are
and these are our
faite
[Music]
snacks This is a
snack that I have
since I was a baby
It's called pus pus
it  means crush it
crush it and It's a
ramen cracker so
You'll break it in
half and you know
kids could be
agressive so they'll
go
like and then you
open it up like
nothing
happens put all the
seasoning in
there you SHAKE
IT lot  of
Noise It's so good I
can eat this all
[Music]
day the tip of
eating this is you
got to eat it till
the end and you have
to go like this and
eat all the
seasoning and the
little crumbs That's
the best
part p
pus  This is my faite
snack I
ate it at home for the first time, and this
was the effect back then, but then I went back to work and
it suddenly
occurred to me. Should I say this tastes a bit like home? Every time I eat that, I feel like I'm at home, so it's
okay.
No, I'm perfect. per  My
sister, who practiced this with me when I was a trainee, said it was
really delicious, so she
gave me this as a gift for her birthday that year, and since
we couldn't get it in Korea, we had it
shipped overseas. It arrived a week later, and that's
right, it's the one above.
Hello,
Krispy
Choco. This is a snack that I liked when I was a child.
Now, it is a snack that I
loved and ate for a long time when I was in kindergarten or elementary school. When I was a child, even though I
liked pizza, it was so
big that I couldn't eat it at all. But for some reason,
I ate a whole pizza.  It feels like it's in the
shape of a pizza. Yeah, that's
why I liked it. Actually, it's a snack that my dad
liked first. It's a snack that I've grown to like since I started eating it because of my dad's spirit. Oh,
this is really delicious
chocolate. It's really, really delicious. It's delicious. I have to
take it too. I have to
take it too.  Wow, let's look at
everyone's
clothes, but there's a lot of flavor,
right? Gaha, you can just stir-fry fire chicken, and this is
not spicy. It's good for people who can't eat spicy food, and it's
a little bit
like the center of spicy food in Korea, so
my spicy food.  If you have it, ask a little bit. It's
spicier than hot chicken fried noodles. It's like hot
chicken fried noodles. I think I'm asking like this. I think it's
become a standard
powerful What a
powerful
Yes LA ketchup I did
n't know this was a
Canadian thing I
thought everyone
loved LE ketchup I
would usually eat
them When I go to
canada to visit my
family there So my
roots are
Here I love these
You cannot find them
anywhere in korea
really Ah Oh this
vinegary ketchup Oh
I love see tangy I
love it cuz It's
tangy and It's sweet
and It's
[Music  ]
[Applause]
ketchup I'm getting
Goosebumps seriously
Oh my god I feel
that I'm Canadian
When I say a it just
comes and goes like
it pops out of
Nowhere I'm like
It's good Oh my god
you can't  find
Anywhere like I
would say a here and
there I'm
for this is one of
my favorite snacks
It's called chi in
Korean I actually
used to have like a
very similar snack
to this It's called
kinoko yama and That
was like what I used
to  eat When I was
like really young
and then When I came
to Korea during
trainy days and all
of that
snore it
Oh yeah, I
ate it. Oh, it's really delicious. It's delicious. Wow, the chocolate is delicious. I didn't eat it before, but it's rice cake. When I was young, I
only sucked the chocolate from this chocolate bunch and took this stick with
my dad.  I gave it to him. It's a bit
weird, but when I was little, I really ate it and
put it in here and here. It's
cute. Chocolate
half and half. Hello, I'm Jiwoo. I
don't remember what snacks I liked when I was little, so I asked my mom, and she said
I liked these snacks.  There
are eggplants.
One type is a short one that looks like noodles, and
one has a star candy. You
have to eat it together. That's right, you have to eat it together.
It has too little soup compared to the others, so
when I was young, I always brought my own and
ate it like this.  There was
something like that. Oh, there was a muscle man.
When I was young, I
was the one who scolded me a lot for not eating those vegetables. I'm
still right. I still don't eat vegetables even now. I think it's a
cookie from my memories.
[Music] A
snack that comes to mind when I was young.
Oh That's it Oh
thank you.  all for
watching US share
our FA snack I had a
blast i had so much
fun Thank you Thank
[Music] [
Music]
youe
[Applause]
[Music]
l